Unpredictable events can drive massive changes
in network needs and traffic patterns, especially
for Communication Service Providers.
To handle extreme levels of network volatility,
they're embracing cloud and virtualization
to deliver the 5G and edge services
that their customers' demand.
Also, many CSPs recognize the potential of
AI to automate problem detection and remediation.
Enter IBM Cloud Pak for Network Automation.
Based on years of IBM experience working with
telecom partners,
IBM Cloud Pak for Network Automation helps CSPs
transform their networks,
evolve to zero-touch operations,
reduce operating expense,
and deliver services faster.
What does this mean for CTOs?
Their teams can rapidly design, deploy, and scale new
services in minutes instead of days, improving
customer responsiveness.
But this transformation demands team players.
Imagine you're a Network Service Engineer.
You’re using the intent-based orchestration
within IBM Cloud Pak for Network Automation
to reduce the work required to launch a new
network service offering.
Bringing a new service online no longer means
racking hardware or manual installation steps.
You start by creating a service package from
a template.
It's composed of a set of
network functions,
services running in containers,
or services from your Virtual Network Functions.
You package and test the newly-assembled components
before deploying them to production.
Once your team is satisfied the offering meets
customer requirements and your quality assurance
standards, the fully tested package is added
to the product catalog.
To save time and avoid human error, catalog
additions are done following an automated
CI/CD process.
With the services available in the catalog,
your customers can order them as needed.
For example, a Mobile Virtual Network Operator
could quickly order a virtual radio access
network, or vRAN, service.
Or an enterprise could order a 5G Network
Slice service for a specific time AND purpose.
Your customers don't need to know what's going
on behind the scenes.
When the order is placed, IBM Cloud Pak for
Network Automation will decide which specific
network functions are required to deliver
that service orchestrated from scratch.
Or, if the service is already up and running,
making the appropriate configuration changes.
In this example, the service order and delivery
were entirely self-service.
No call-in was required!
Once the service is deployed, IBM Cloud Pak for Network Automation,
combined with IBM Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps,
automatically monitors the environment by tracking events,
key performance indicators, and
changes in the network topology.
Here's the main dashboard for network operations
that interests your Site Reliability Engineers,
or SREs - it shows a real-time health status
of the network and services along with correlated
events and a service topology overview.
Although automation may take place without
human intervention,
the SRE can validate what the system has done.
They don't have to watch the dashboard minute-by-minute,
and they have a full history of key system events.
By proactively dealing with network anomalies
ahead of customer impact, your operations
team will have fewer fire drills and less
need for human intervention.
But sometimes applying an automated resolution
isn't prudent.
For such cases, IBM Cloud Pak for Network
Automation notifies the appropriate engineer
with AI-based recommendations for next best actions.
So, to wrap this up, IBM Cloud Pak for Network
Automation can help you rapidly design, deploy,
and scale new services in minutes instead of days.
And it helps you lower costs by moving your
team towards zero-touch operations.
The best part: since it’s built on Red Hat
OpenShift, you can run it on any cloud, anywhere.
Thanks for watching. If you have any questions,
please add a comment below.
If you want to see more videos like this in the future,
please like and subscribe.